Welcome
back to Gary’s Economics.
Today we're going to talk
about the tax burden.
So this is
an economic story
which comes up a lot
in the news,
which is the idea
that at the moment
the tax burden is at an
all time historic high.
Now, I'm
pretty sure this is
a basically
a factual truth.
And it's something that
when it first started
to get mentioned, it
kind of confused me
a little bit.
And I think it will have
confused a lot of people.
The reason it confused me
is because
we have two things
happening simultaneously,
which kind of appear
to be like
paradoxically impossible,
which is, number one,
you have the tax burden
at an all time high.
And that's true.
You guys will see that,
especially things
like council tax rising
really significantly.
And at the same time,
we have this situation
where basically
all government services
seem to be collapsing
simultaneously.
Everything seems to be
constantly
in crisis,
NHS is in crisis.
Education is in crisis,
especially things
like local
services are in crisis.
So how can it be possible
that on the one hand
taxes are the highest
they've ever been
and on the other hand,
government
services are like
the worst
they've ever been, or
they've been in decades.
Taxes pay for government
services, so
if taxes are super high,
how can government
services be
super terrible? And
the reason which is often
given for this
and I think it's really
increased the popularity
of the idea,
is basically that
government is corrupt.
Government is corrupt,
so we’re
paying loads of taxes.
Government p*sses
the taxes up the wall.
You know,
let's get rid of taxes,
let's get rid
of government services.
And I think,
you know, there probably
some truth to this.
I think there's probably
always been
some degree of government
corruption.
Government corruption
may well be higher now
than it has been
historically.
If you look at some of
the things that happened
during COVID,
some of the sort of
Conservative Party
scandals,
it does look like
corruption is increasing.
But I'm not an expert on
the levels of government
corruption.
I don't
work in government.
But I've been sitting and
thinking about this
for a while.
I don't think it's enough
to say that
corruption has suddenly
increased massively.
And the more
I thought about this,
the more I realised
there is another
really obvious factor,
which basically
never gets discussed,
which I want to explain
to you today,
which explains
really well
basically
why the tax burden
has increased
and probably
will continue to increase
despite the fact that
government
services are collapsing.
I think the best way
to explain this
is to use an example.
Imagine you own
completely
your own house.
No mortgage, no rent,
you own your own house.
Some of you will be
in that position.
Most of you won't be
Now, imagine
you are in that position.
How expensive
will your life be?
Well, for most people,
their housing cost
is their single biggest
expense in their life.
Be that through paying
rent or paying mortgage,
if you own your own house
outright,
you don't need to pay
rent,
you don't need
to pay mortgage.
And basically
your costs in life are
very low compared
to somebody else.
Now, let's imagine
situation changes
and suddenly
you lose that house,
you completely lose
that house, and now you
still need to leave,
but you don't own
your house.
Your costs
will massively increase
because you have to pay
rent for a whole house,
or you have to pay
a mortgage
on a whole house.
So if you own your house,
your expenditures in life
are much lower
than if you don't
own your own house.
Now, keep this example
in mind
and we're going to start
thinking
about the government.
So I talk a lot on this
channel about increases
in inequality of wealth
and what I say
very often is
that there are two groups
in society
who are losing
their wealth.
That is ordinary
working families
like you,
unless you’re very rich
and the government.
And both of these groups
have lost their wealth
significantly.
Now, of course,
if you're
an ordinary family,
especially if you're
a young person from
from an ordinary family,
it would be very visible
to you
that ordinary families
are losing their wealth
because you'll be
probably
struggling to buy a home.
Or you may
be in a situation
where you think
you can never buy a home
compared
to older generations,
who could buy property.
But the loss of
government
wealth is often
a lot less visible
because we don't,
you know, we are not
the government,
we don't think about what
the government owns.
So I went to a talk
by famous French
inequality
economist Thomas
Piketty, of whom
I'm quite a big fan,
a few years ago
when I was at Oxford
and he showed us a graph
which I still remember
today,
and we're going to
show you that graph now,
which basically shows you
government
wealth holding.
So what you can see
in this graph is that
all of the countries
in this graph,
the wealth
holding of governments
has decreased
significantly over time.
So that one
line at the top is China.
You won't be surprised,
the Chinese government
is essentially
a communist country.
The government owns
a lot of the wealth
in the country.
The other countries on
the graph
are all
Western countries.
So you've got the USA
on there, UK in there,
Germany, Japan, I think
France is on there.
And the story of the
rest of these countries
is basically
all the same.
They’ve all the...
the wealth
holding of the government
has decreasing
significantly over time.
And I want you to notice
that in the case of both
the UK and the US,
that number went below
0% in the early 2010s.
So the aftermath of the
2008 financial crisis.
So what that means
is the total wealth of
the UK government,
the US government and
basically every other
Western government
is in a pretty similar
situation,
is now below zero.
So that means these guys
have debts
bigger than their assets.
Note that
that graph ends in 2014.
The situation
during COVID
got significantly worse,
so now these graphs will
drop down significantly
and what you will see
is significant
negative wealth holding
for the British
government,
for the American
basically
every Western government.
Now, I
want you to remember
the story I told you
about you and your house,
because
Western governments,
including the British
and American governments,
are basically
in this situation.
Back sort of 50
years ago,
Western governments
had a lot of wealth.
They essentially own
their own house.
Now, of course, when we
talk about governments,
it's not just housing.
We're talking about
governments
owning things like
hospitals, like schools.
But of course,
in the case of the UK,
the UK government
did own also
a significant amount
of housing back
in the seventies.
Governments have lost
this wealth now.
So governments
are in the same situation
basically as you would be
if you lost your home.
So governments,
you know,
they provide, in the West
a lot of services,
education, health care.
They used to provide
housing
for the poorest
people in the countries
and they
were able to do this
because they owned
the wealth,
they owned hospitals,
they owned schools,
they owned housing.
And what we learned
from that Piketty graph
that I showed you
is that basically Western
governments do not own
any wealth anymore.
And the fact that
the number has dropped
below zero,
means that not only do
they not own wealth,
they're actually
in a significant
amount of debt.
So what does that mean?
Governments
still need to provide you
with health care,
but they don't own
the hospital.
Governments
still need to provide you
with education,
but they don't own
the school.
Governments
still need to provide
the poorest people
in society with housing,
but they don't own
the homes.
Now, things like health
care and education
are never very cheap
to provide anyway.
You need
to pay for doctors, you
need to pay for teachers.
But they're a
lot cheaper to provide
when you own
the buildings.
If you don't own
the building,
then you need to pay
rent on the building.
If you have a massive
amount of debt,
then you need to pay
interest on that debt.
So now governments
are in situations,
just as you are in,
previously they didn't
need to pay that rent,
they didn't need to pay
that debt interest,
and now
they've got to pay it.
What that means is
if they want
to provide you
with the same level
of service
that they used
to provide you with 30,
40, 50 years ago,
they simply need
more tax money
because they no longer
own the assets
and they need to pay rent
or interest
on those assets.
So I think this is
a really important thing
for you to understand,
and it really completely
explains the situation
that we are in.
The reason
that governments
are having to charge
much higher levels of tax
to provide much worse
levels of service
is quite simply
because governments are
much, much poorer now.
Governments
are really poor.
And when governments are
rich,
they have
what you could call in
modern lingo
passive income,
you know,
they own the property,
they don't need to pay
for the property
and they can use
those passive incomes
to provide you
with government services.
Governments are no longer
rich.
Governments
are now very poor.
They need to rent
everything they use,
they need
to pay interest.
And that means
they've taken that money
from you.
And despite
taking more money
from you, they can't
provide services.
That is what happens
when you go
from being rich
to being poor.
Now, this wouldn't
necessarily be a problem
if the assets
which the government
has lost, the wealth
has lost,
were held
by ordinary families.
So, you know, one thing
I want you to realise is
this loss in government
wealth, you know,
these assets,
these hospitals,
these schools,
they have not
disappeared.
They're all still here.
These assets must
have gone to somebody.
And if those assets had
gone to ordinary people,
it wouldn't necessarily
be a problem.
I think the best example
to illustrate
that is the council
housing, right?
So when council housing
was sold off in sort of
the ‘80s and the ’90s,
the people who benefited
from that initially
were the people who lived
in the council houses.
Council houses
were given to poorer
people, so it benefited
the poor people.
Now the government didn't
have the homes,
but the people who needed
the housing
owned their own homes.
So it wasn't initially
a problem
if it was just
a transfer of wealth
from the government
to the people,
then it wouldn't
necessarily matter
because the people
would be richer now.
They could pay more taxes
or the government
wouldn't
need to provide
so many services
because you directly
would own things
like your own homes.
The problem that we have
is that actually
in the last,
you know, 30, 40 year
period
in which you have seen
governments
have massively
lost their wealth.
We have also seen
a significant
loss of wealth
in ordinary families.
And I think this is
something I talk about
a lot on the channel,
but it is most visible
in two things.
Number one,
the massively decreased
home ownership rates
for young people.
You know, here
in this country
and in the US,
ordinary families,
their wealth tends
to be in housing.
So if younger people
are not getting housing,
it's a sign
that families are losing
their wealth.
And number two,
the massively
increased debt levels
for ordinary families,
especially families
who manage
to get a mortgage.
So I think
this creates a kind of
interesting and
confusing paradox, right.
Which is
how can it be possible
that government has lost
its wealth
and ordinary families
who lost their wealth?
Now the government
gave, for example,
the council housing
to ordinary families.
Now you have a situation
where
both ordinary families
and governments
are struggling
to get housing.
And I think this reveals
the core of the problem,
which is something
I talk about
a lot on this channel,
which is that wealth,
which transferred
initially
from the government
to ordinary families,
has over time
ended up being held
by the very rich.
And you know,
this happens to...
If you want to understand
the mechanism of this,
you should
watch the video
we put a couple of weeks
ago called
How You Lose Your House,
which is ordinary people
got this wealth
from the government.
They use that wealth
to support their lives,
to support
their retirements,
to pay
for end of life care.
And they ended up
selling that wealth
to the rich.
The end situation is
we end up in a place
where both the government
and ordinary families
have very little wealth.
Now, this is.
it’s kind of a disastrous
situation, right.
Because we've
already learned
the government is
struggling
to provide basic services
now because
government is poor.
What does it mean if on
top of that, ordinary
families are poor?
Well, that means
ordinary families
can't afford housing,
which means
they really need housing.
But the government
who used to have housing
doesn't
have housing either,
so they can't provide you
with housing.
It also means that
people are living
lives of greater poverty.
They will live in worse
conditions,
they will even worse
housing.
They will eat worse
diets,
they will have more
stress.
They will probably face
more crime,
which means they'll need
more health care.
But the government can't
provide more health care
because the government
has no assets.
So I think this
really realises,
makes real the problem
that I talk about
on this channel.
So people who’ve
watched for a long time
will know
I'm very, very worried
about growing
inequality of wealth.
And I think
people have become
used to the idea
that inequality
is a social problem.
They’re used to, kind
of, people on the left
arguing that we need less
inequality
because it's unfair.
It's not good
for society.
My worry is deeper than
that.
My worry
is that when you have
very high levels
of inequality,
what it means is
you can't get
basic
essential needs like
housing and health
care and education.
You know,
in our economy
we have a distribution
of resources.
If both governments
and ordinary families are
losing their wealth,
that wealth is
going to the super rich.
And we've seen a ton
of statistics
which show us that
the super rich
have enormously
increased their wealth
in the last three years,
we had the biggest ever
one year rise of wealth
by superrich in the
first year of COVID.
If we give all of the
resources to the rich,
if we bankrupt
both ordinary families
and the government,
the consequence is
your family
can't get a house,
your family can't get
health care,
education,
and the government
won't be able
to provide them
because
they are also poor.
So I think
once you recognise
that that is the problem,
that governments
have lost their wealth
and therefore they can't
provide services,
the only option
that they appear to feel
they have is to tax
the middle class
who are
also losing their assets.
You realise that
the fundamental
question here
and the only real way
to solve this problem
is to get the assets
back, basically.
And that doesn't
necessarily mean
increasing
the size of government.
It could mean
transferring assets back
from the very rich
to the middle class,
to the working classes.
And the fundamental
question is
how do you get
those assets back?
And I think if you want
to address that question,
how do you get the assets
back?
It is very helpful
to consider yourself
from the position
of a wealthy person.
So consider you all like,
a rich person, but
not a super rich person.
So say you've got a net
worth of £5 million,
which is of course
a lot, but the very rich
have much, much
more than that.
If you have a net worth
of £5 million,
lets assume you’re able
to make 5% a year on that
£5 million,
you might make a bit
less.
5% of £5 million
is £250,000 a year.
Lets assume you make a bit less. £200,000 a year.
This is passive
income, you
get this on
top of your work,
you don't do any work
to get it.
You're making £200,000
a year.
How much money
would you spend?
Imagine
you suddenly had a
passive income
of £200,000 a year.
You know,
the ordinary person
probably spends £20,000
to £30,000 a year.
I suspect you probably
raised your spending
to £60,000 a year,
maybe £70,000 a year,
which would massively
improve your lifestyle.
And you still have
another £130,000 a year
passive income,
which you could use
to buy more assets.
Now, in a strong economy
that is growing rapidly,
you might be able to use
this money
to create more assets.
But we don't live
in a strong economy
that's growing rapidly,
we haven't for some time.
You're probably going
to use this money to buy
existing assets,
probably from the middle
class,
probably
from the government.
But the big problem
you have here,
you will never sell
your assets, will you?
If you have £5
million in assets,
you've got £160,000
a year passive income,
which you use to grow
your assets.
You will never,
ever sell your assets.
So if we exist
in an economy
which is not
really growing,
the rich will never sell
their assets.
Not only that,
they will continue
to buy more assets.
You can see that
it is already
and will become
increasingly impossible
for the government
or for you
as an ordinary family
to ever get
any of your assets back.
So, you know, this is
the situation we are in.
Government
is taxing you a lot
to pay
for sh*tty services
because
government's bankrupt
and you can't afford
to pay those taxes
because ordinary families
are bankrupt
and all of that wealth
is gone to the rich
who are going to use it
to buy
the rest of the wealth,
making
you even more bankrupt.
And this essentially
is the reason why
what I always campaign
for is significantly
higher taxes
on the very rich,
because I don't see
any other way of you
getting your assets back.
And I want to talk
a little bit
about how this could
work, how we could make
this society better.
I think the only way
you get wealth flowing
in the other direction,
you tax very rich people
much, much more.
You use that money
to significantly reduce
taxes on working people.
Your taxes are less.
So you start to be able
to accumulate
a bit of money.
Rich people's
taxes are much, much more
so they need
to sell their assets
in order to pay
for the taxes.
You've got more money.
The rich need to sell
assets.
You ordinary working
families can start to buy
those assets
back from the rich.
So the reason I support
higher
taxation on the rich
is because, number one,
it's the only way
to reduce your taxes.
And number two, it's
the only way for you,
ordinary families,
to get your assets back.
The point
I want to make here is,
you know,
when I talk about taxes,
we're in an interesting
place here in society
where,
you know, understandably,
the middle class
is getting quite heavily
taxed, largely
because the rich pay
very low taxes.
And if you haven't
watched,
I would encourage
you to watch our video
Who Pays Tax?
Because
the very rich often pay
very,
very low rates of tax.
And that has led
to a situation
where ordinary people
and particularly
slightly higher earning
people, middle class
people
are very opposed to tax.
And yet tax
is essentially
the only way that they
will ever get richer.
So ordinary
people have been
put in a situation
where for very
understandable reasons,
they oppose
the only possible
policy measure
which could
save them from poverty.
And I think, you know,
this is supported
by ideas
like tax is wasted,
like tax is corrupt,
like tax goes
to a corrupt government.
Taxing the rich can be
used to lower your taxes
and that is the only way
that you can get
your assets
back from wealthy people.
If we don't tax them,
they will continue
to never sell any assets
have enormous amounts
of passive income
which they and their kids
will use to outcompete
you and your kids
for the assets
which you currently own
and in the end
your family will own
nothing.
So listen, tax for me
is...
it's not about increasing
the size of government.
It's not about more
levels of government
spending.
Tax for me
is about defending
ordinary families
from the growing power
and wealth of the rich.
It's about getting wealth
back into the
hands of ordinary people,
and it's about making
life better,
or at the very least
stopping life
from getting worse.
So to conclude,
I would like to make
the clear point
that the only way
to reduce the tax burden
for you, for ordinary
families like you,
is to increase taxes.
But to increase taxes on
the rich.
We're going to campaign
for it.
We're here every week.
Tell your friends.
Tell your mum. Thank you.